by the way just before we get started
how was your weekend and he was it okay
oh it was fun yeah I took the family to
the beach and oh you know who I saw
there Sofia Vergara that's cool you saw
Sofia Vergara at the beach I did Conan
and you know what you won't believe the
bathing suit she was wearing I'm sorry
what the hell is that
and while we're at the beach we saw this
guy with a metal detector and you know
what you won't believe the priceless
treasure this beach bum dug up Andy what
are you doing
it's called clickbait you tease the
story people click on the link and we
get paid by the click it makes money for
the show makes money on a computer but
not on television well that's how people
watch our show now they wash it on
computers and iPads and cell phones but
Google's next device will make all your
screens obsolete by next year okay
that's enough Andy cut it out no
clickbait ting all right all right but
you're leaving money on the table how
much money Jeff a lot a lot of money
really it's a lot of money a lot of
cabbage Wow
now one said that in 60 years all right
[Applause]
anyway we have a great show tonight
creator and star of the new Fox series
the last man on earth
Will Forte is here
you know I say something honey I love
Will Forte you know what I also love
this one weird trick that prevents all
migraines a new Comedy Central special
sleight of mouth magician Justin Willman
is on the program he's great here's my
question
did he really hook up with one of these
hotties huh hey musical guest Mack
DeMarcos on the show
but you're really going to love watching
these Easter puppy cuties check it out
[Music]
yeah
[Applause]
you